hey I've got something to show you
we want to shoot a Minecraft WWE video
question becomes what we should make the
costumes out of and how flexible and
durable they should be what are you
doing trying to find boxes some right
here yeah I know the thing is I can't
it's complicated we're asked to do a
online commercial something that we want
to build is a bit of a commercial
production arm in addition to everything
else we do this is a good opportunity to
start that process so it is a
pitch-black room right now yes I know
exactly where you are that's the sound
of a splinter cell like goggles turning
on so as you can see there is absolutely
zero light in this room but there is
heat I can't see I will fall on the
toilet so this is the original minecraft
one three zombies one Steve and a John
Cena right now I'm working on the bodies
and I'm just going to assembly line and
hopefully we can actually reuse some of
the arms and leg pieces like these
things yeah maybe not the legs it's a
little bit different than a traditional
YouTube video because the client expects
like a lot of different things
reproduction book and nice casting in a
nice location and all these different
details that we normally don't do so
it's definitely a learning curve for me
let's do some hand prints here we go
three ooh
gross I left a mark look over here
where's over here
what are you hammering there cardboard I
have to crease this cardboard
artificially you score one side then you
take this mallet fold it where you want
it and you hit it I'm gonna do it are
now typing it out looking at my fingers
let me read back to you acted after back
on the nice thing about just doing a
commercial is that as you like try to
balance out trying to make a piece of
content for our audience while working
in a brand integration or anything like
that I can just straight up not worry
about it and just blatantly a brand this
thing and it's kind of liberating taking
the script from PowerPoint slash PDF
form and putting it into actual script
form and final draft Stan ice just going
through
so I get to like see it in my head as I
kind of rewrite it this is what I do
when no one's around like in the pitch
blackness but only now you can see it
can you like lean against the wall or
really believing oh my god you'll never
talk about of this it's a Micro Machines
r2d2 for our Star Wars video so there
you go now in the star war this is
actually rather nerve-wracking Oh Nico
hasn't told me anything about this I
know nothing about this video